دخل اسطوره سباقات السيارات فورمولا واحد
الالماني مايكل شوماخر في غيبوبه وحالته
حرجه اثر تعرضه لاصابات في الراس في حادث
التزلج بجبال القلب الفرنسيه وذكرت مصادر
طبيه في مستشفى جرينوبل ان شوماخر بحاجه
الى جراحه عاجله في الدماغ وكان بحاله
غيبوبه ساعه نقله الى المستشفى بعد اصطدام
راسه بصخره عقب سقوطه اثناء
التزلج ويعرف الاسطوره الالماني وهو في صف
العقد الرابع من العمر بانه انجح سائقي
فورملا واحد لفوزه في 71 سباقا قبل
اعتزاله العام
الماضي وقال وكيل شومخر في بيان نشر على
موقع فورملا واحد ان الحادث وقع اثناء
رحله تزلج خاصه مضيفا نرجو تفهم صعوبه
تقديم معلومات مستمره حول صحته كان يرتدي
خوذ وكان لوحده اما فيما يخص سقوطه فما من
شخص
متورط